this is my favorite video that I have
seen at least this week maybe this year
and it's of a nun in France a Catholic
nun who is on the site of a new Chapel
that is being built when a bunch of
climate protesters show up these
left-wing Gaia worshipping pagans show
up to destroy the construction site so
what is the nun going to do is the nun
going to just sit meekly back is the
nun only going to pray I'm sure the nun
was praying about this a lot and that's
very important thing to do that's the
most important thing to do at first but
then there are other things that we can
do such as tackle the climate
protesters There She Goes drag him slay
sister yes get that jerk in the muck
then the other ones go and they keep
trying to D destroy the construction
equipment but that sister oh I love it
there are too many pacifists in the
church militant if you ask me I
absolutely love
that you know they say faith without
works is dead which is sometimes
misinterpreted to mean that we can earn
our own salvation through works and
that's not the case God's grace comes
all the way down the mountain we can
cooperate with that Grace or not and and
a a life of faith is going to look like
something and it's going to impel
certain action
such as tackling the climate activists
who are trying to destroy your property
and a beautiful Chapel that could be
built the reason though that this video
really struck me and I think the reason
it's going viral right now and it
pertains to what we were just talking
about with feminism is under feminism
women seem empowered but are in fact
powerless right women uh they they seem
like they're boss babes but actually
they just get used by a bunch of men as
sexual toys and then discarded they they
are dragged out for activism you know
and they they smile on camera but then
they're discarded they they're told that
they're empowered to go sit in the
office at the widget Factory and engage
in drudgery all day and have to put off
getting married and have to put off
having kids and have to put off being
The Hand That Rocks the Cradle is the
hand that rules the world right now go
to Ruff greens.com you know I'm not a
dog person I'm a people person but my
step brother he has a little dog and
while I'm lukewarm on my stepbrother you
know the dog should be healthy which is
why I sent him rough greens and they
absolutely love it naturopathic doctor
Dennis black the founder of Ruff greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America dog food may as
well be considered dead food because it
contains very little nutritional content
think about it nutrition is not brown
it's green let rough greens bring your
dogs food back to life rough greens how
many times I going to say it a lot is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on your
food every single day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels it does a
whole lot more than that and right now
my listeners are going to get a free
jump start trial bag so that your dog
can try it get that free jump start
trial bag delivered straight to your
door just a few business days Ru
greens.com or call 844
rf123 rfg greens.com
or call 844
rf123 today so the pr coming out of
media and Hollywood is these feminist
women they're so empowered but they're
miserable and in fact if you trust
surveys on happiness their happiness
since feminism going back to the very
moment of the rise of feminism their
happiness has declined both both
absolutely and relative to men and
ironically under traditional gender
roles women seem subservient women seem
like they're in a secondary role in fact
however they are extremely empowered if
you have ever met a real nun I get to
spend some time with some some sisters
some pro-life sisters in Southern
California at a a pro-life Gala a few
weeks ago these are some of the toughest
ladies you ever saw in your life and
they are doing lots of good and they're
not going to take no for an answer not
certainly not from unjust Authority and
they're they're forces to be reckoned
with you ever meet a true matriarch of a
family often she will defer to her
husband the husband's the head of the
household she will look like a 1950s
housewife she might look like a 1250s
housewife she has a lot of power this is
the meaning of the phrase the hand That
Rocks the Cradle is the hand that rules
the world the the reason that that is
always the case is because when you live
in accordance with nature and reality
you will succeed more you will be more
perfectly yourself if you try to do the
opposite if if you fall into the the LIE
of feminism which says that the only way
to have power or do good is to act like
a man to put on a suit and in some cases
now to transform your body to look more
like a man uh you're going to be acting
out of accord with nature out of accord
with reality and you're never going to
beat reality you when when you and
reality go up in the boxing match
reality is always going to win you will
you will become a caricature of yourself
and what you're supposed to be rather
than the perfect version of yourself and
ultimately we reach our full Perfection
when we cooperate with God's grace and
accept God's grace which is why that
none is just absolutely crushing it and
crushing that protester boy what a great
clip that was now h h Huh huh ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael nolles
YouTube channel we'll see you next time